the visit is a stereoscopic display that
was originally built for the purpose of
getting a real-time imaging system on
set when we're shooting the one bullets
video if you're really interested in 3d
and you have an aversion to the red and
blue and live glasses then you would
want something like this because this is
a polarized stereoscopic display and you
get true color you do wear glasses but
they're polarized glasses so instead of
red and cyan filters this just kind of
is like a slight gray so it doesn't mess
with the Kelly law LCDs have natural
polarization built into them which
corresponds with the glasses so a lot of
the work is done for you if you get a
display that that is polarized if you're
gonna make your own Vizard the first
thing you'll need to do is build a
enclosure for it inside the most crucial
thing is that the two monitors are
perfect 90-degree angles to each other
and that the mirror that goes inside
sits exactly 45 degrees to the monitors
and then these little blocks in the
front have notches that hold them here
so the displays slide in one on the back
I have this has buttons on the bottom so
I have little foam pads that keep the
buttons from being push and you set it
in there
this one goes on the top and it's
supposed to be like the tops touching so
it's the top of this monitor this is the
top of this display so this one sits in
like that like they're mirroring each
other so to speak and then this is this
over here is a mayor that's just as
reflective as it is transparent it's
called a 50/50 mare sometimes they
called a half-silvered Mila
Mir um this one's made out of acrylic
but you can get really nice ones made
out of glass they've got coins scratch
easily need to get all so much but
there's a really cheap so then it just
fits in there like that this is the the
basic configuration of the visit and now
I can show you how to play back video on
this program is called stereo movie
player and you can download it for free
on the internet
and I prepared a Windows Media File of
the 1ls video this is the right eyes
image and this is the left eyes image
and the the right has been flipped to
compensate for this mirror that's in
here since the the image will be hitting
a mirror needs to be flipped so that it
goes back to more and if I just slide
this window over to the right you can
see that's the top screen
and images just coming down in the
mirror and their alliance when you
it's basically superimposing two images
over each other
to fullscreen something like that you
can kind of slide these around to get it
to line up perfectly
you